wife do you want to be
I feel like um I was born quite maternal
quite wisely and I
sometimes it's a con because you carry
worthy duties before when you did
girlfriend prices when I am a wife
um I have kind of similar views I'll you
know I want to raise my children to a
certain age and then they can get into
education or whatever
um if during that time my man is the
provider then I'll have to step up and
do most homey things but then when I do
continue to go back to work or start
providing also whether it's for everyone
or just you know partly
um I'd want him to step in slightly more
and maybe one night help with the
cooking or unload the dishwasher I don't
think it should be all on me
um
but yeah I'm a very given person I'm
very caring nurturing person so whatever
he needs if you need help within his
work or you know I'll always try I won't
I won't ever say no or decline anything
I always try okay could I could I get
more specifics because this is just very
broad specific in what like what what
exactly you would do every day like as a
wife
and you said like you did this stuff at
like wifey things at girlfriend oh yeah
what does that mean no cook I clean you
know I'd wake up make the bed if do you
think do you think a man paying for a
date is doing husband things at
boyfriend prices
do I think a man paid off yeah I'm
paying for a date is that doing husband
things at boyfriend prices because a lot
of times I think like we say we cooked
we cleaned and that's that's wifey
things our girlfriend prices but then
they protect and provide possibly yeah
okay so you think a man shouldn't pay
unless he marries you no I don't think
that but if you know I'm choosing to
cook and clean you can choose to pay if
you want to pay if you don't want to pay
I'm not getting on to you about that
same way if I don't cook you're not
going to get on to me about that we're
not at that level yet they might get
under you about it they might they have
the choice to but I also have the choice
to you know but I feel like if you don't
display that you can do those things
then you're not going to get to that
marriage stage
just start looking after the kids not
necessarily but I just mean like the
cooking and the cleaning that's a
slippery slope because women then like
they want to show you all they've got in
their locker and then I was like oh I
might as well just chill like this okay
they get used to it yeah that's not
something why is it that when women talk
about doing stuff for a man the first
one they talk about cooking and cleaning
like a man can't do it yourself they
never talk about I want to hear but the
men can cook and clean nowadays every
man can't cook and clean you shouldn't
be with them your husband can cook and
clean he's got cake ball looking after
himself so he's got the kids they're
just talking about doing something that
a man could already do for himself
what's the next suggestion I don't think
there's any right or wrong answer for
that I think everyone's everyone's
marriage is going to be different I
think we're all saying the right things
personally that's how I feel I think
just add to each other's life when you's
not getting married invite me please I'd
like to see what's that that's all I'm
saying invite me I can't wait to get
married I can't wait for you to get
married I'd love you I can't wait for
you to get married I can't wait what
would you suggest adding to the resume
I know there's some things that we've
been working on like we're making a
cookbook I think they need to um
borrow their nieces and nephews two and
a half term it's half term if they live
on their own then get a couple of days
off have them ran let the parents just
leave them there then get on with it
listen I understand it's not just
cooking and cleaning like I've for
example been a nanny before I give him
sex every night as well yeah on top of
the cooking and cleaning and looking
after the kids and doing the shopping
and getting all the delivery done and so
in that all his paperwork is that what
we were missing sex
what do you think a man would say
your life is you're
excited to merge both your lives
together and then you
threw it
it's not like you have one role and I
have one role we just we're doing it I
feel like fits I do feel um I I think in
my marriage I definitely feel like that
would be set roles yes
I was gonna say if the man was at home
all day and you've got all them kids in
that and you're still gonna fit in Sex
Room though
yeah when they're napping
what's their nap
there's ways around it
I think the kids love like was it cocoa
melon and whatever just how can melon
Gray's corner of them
they're walking you know Jump Around
Peppa Pig comments are saying that these
answers are very vague I don't even know
what they're saying
well I'm not gonna go into like you know
okay as a non-married woman there's
people saying I'm being vague
I would wake up make sure everyone's
alive and well I'd start going about my
day think about what I'm gonna do if I
have children I'm getting them ready if
my husband's going to work and I'm still
looking after the kids at home he can go
off to work you okay if you eat and cool
never know about your day be on about
your way I'll take care of the kids if
we've got any stuff coming up try to
take them for a walk hopefully the
dishwasher's done by the night before
empty it out go about my business think
about what I'm gonna cook look in the
fridge start preparing that one's
watching TV One's in their little Walker
oh it's lovely how's your day as it is
now
would you don't forget to change your
nappies live in now all right let me let
me just see if this matches right go on
you wake up early in the morning I'm
just talking as a grandparent when I got
the grandkids right
I'll be getting dinner ready the night
before so I wake up about four half four
in the morning do me meditation for an
hour not an hour oh my gosh you can stay
focused for that long exactly that's
your problem
and I do half past four in the morning
and then I will start getting the
clothes will be sorted from the night
before dinner ready for the night before
Pearl knows that mudding is cooked by
nine o'clock in the morning
and one of the dinners cooking the kids
are dressed they're washed and they're
dressed and then we will have breakfast
together
and then I might have to take them out
or do some kind of work with them go in
the garden and do bits in the garden
then it's lunch then it's painting then
it's crossed and you've got to clear up
and then you've got to think about
calming down everybody have dinner
together you still get the washing up
you still got the washing to do you
still got the housework to do and
get the kids ready for bed sort out
dinner for the next day spend time with
your husband and still got to give him
good sex and still wake up early in the
morning does it sound like like a day
and the extras that you put in because I
know you're busier than that I'm just a
grandmother in my head that's what the
day sounds like I just couldn't I just
couldn't get it out because
I can imagine no I know that's what I'm
trying to because it sounds like oh
wonderful but we're just I just want to
show you reality but it's not wonderful
yeah I don't think it's wonderful at all
you've got one baby in one hand you're
trying to stir something in the other I
understand that wonderful it is
wonderful like it's wonderful but at the
same time like I'm not saying it's going
to be in this easy smooth ride and I'm
just gonna be like oh because the
morning then we'll learn how to make
kids and like no obviously they're all
you are going to go through your own
internal struggles and battles and
Mentor as well
but I'm just saying nobody cares about
that when you're a wife and a mother I'm
I'm just saying that I don't mind I
wanna I wanna I wanna hear what wait
could we uh oh yeah no I want you to go
because they've both been married so
they could both so I want to do the
single people first okay
um what kind of wife do you want to be
oh off the sorry I did that thing where
you breathe in the mic I think off the
basis of my previous relationships and
from what I've learned
because I've never been married I think
I could provide emotional support moral
support
um
so can you say emotional support I I
need to know exactly what that is if
you're gonna come to me and tell me you
have a mental disorder or if you know
anything you want to keep dating guys
with mental distance no but you know
I don't believe in the perfect person
okay okay we're gonna get a sane one but
yeah right right
and I just want someone lovely that
doesn't stress me out okay you just
picked the guy with the mental disorder
I don't looking they just find me maybe
maybe it says something about me anyway
but okay right I would provide a safe
space for them to be honest with me
about anything so we can have
conversations rather than arguments I
think that's important that's really
important okay so how would you do that
what is that I'm very good at resonating
with people I can call myself out and
self-reflect I have the capacity to do
that when no when I'm wrong so so if he
he says something to you then you'll say
I was wrong yeah okay if I was wrong
yeah okay because No One's Gonna Die
saying that okay so you're able to say
you were wrong yeah it's just when
you're talking it's very vague so I'm
just trying to make it more specific
yeah I'll give them the safe space to
know that we can have those
conversations where they can call me out
or I can call them out and we couldn't
come to a conclusion so yeah so you'll
say to him I'll admit when I'm wrong
yeah okay so that's the safe space as
you'll admit as long as I have that back
in return for me to feel yeah yeah okay
but you won't do that unless he says I
was wrong too I will do that but I'd
expect it back I worded that so
incorrectly my bad
um so that
um I'm very very very passionate
um I'm fun so I don't think anyone could
be bored around me when they know me
what does your day look like thank you
as a wife what would your day look like
you wake up like this sounds great for a
girlfriend
fair enough but as a wife oh god I've
never I haven't bought this for a long
time you're applying for a job right
it's like if we if you're applying for a
job you're gonna have a resume if these
are the skills I've had this is the
experience I have doing that you might
say like nanny for two years that'd be
great you know whatever I have been a
nanny actually okay but doesn't it
really kind of depend on the person
you're with to answer that question
correctly I mean if if I apply I can
apply for a shitty job and a good job
but I'm gonna interview the same yeah
it's your CV what your what you're
bringing to the table
I'm gonna I'm gonna cook home-cooked
meals and stuff like that I mean it
would be nice to know exactly what home
cooked meal like the more details the
better so yeah
predominantly being West Indian food If
I Loved Someone that much to marry them
I would learn to cook what they want to
eat I would my question is what do you
know now so again this is like going to
a job and saying hey I'll learn whatever
you want to teach me and then they're
like okay what skills and experience do
you have and you're like well I'll learn
whatever you say
if okay I'm loyal I know that I'm very
loyal I'm very honest I'm very loyal and
those are my those are she asked what
your day is looking like okay yeah all
right
um I think it's okay to say I don't know
as well I don't know my life but I'm
really not that sure yeah that's an okay
answer yeah I'm in the Arts like my life
I'm gonna be honest my life is chaotic I
wouldn't want to marry me I would not
want to marry me so I haven't actually
thought in depth about that question I
don't think I'm a good candidate to
answer that okay do you want to get
married there yeah I in good time but
not for a long as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible